well my distinguished contact
use to use this stage
her but by all we just have heard it's
clear that exactly the political goal is
behind the desire to associate with
western union he was your European Union
because it's clear from what you
gentlemen just said that you want to
draw EU to your fight against all your
quarrel your dispute against Russia whom
you blame 22 now in all mortal sins I
will not contest if they were regular
Russian army there the picture of photos
of that from the space etc would be all
over European newspapers it's not of
course and can I just show you a few
sociological diagrams just to show you
you don't need to just come to mind the
colors it's before my done one is 920 10
and the other is just the first orange
revolution it's the year 04 look how
about the parts of Ukraine without any
Russian influence or invasion so these
are two parts who look different at the
world and by of course even by what you
have just gentleman said you want to
reinforce this one part one part of
minds of Ukrainians by the support of EU
so it's purely political against the
other will it bring harmony to the to
Europe in general will it bring harmony
to Ukraine because it's clear i think
everybody must agree that the main goal
of any big job political act
should be some noble go to harmonize
something to bring peace to bring profit
into in economics and in social life
except will it bring profit for you
believe me although I am a supporter of
our politics the present current state
of psychological war between Ukraine and
Russia is a permanent burning wound in
my heart since the grave of my ancestors
light in Ukraine my father academician
Naruto Netsky was born in chernigov and
graduated from Kiev University he could
deliver a lecture in Ukrainian my
grandfather who died before revolution
was director of people's college in
ensure [ __ ] and his father migrant
grandfather was a Orthodox priest in
chernigov region so for me it's a
tragedy all this so but just not because
of I'm interested that instead of
joining European Union even in the form
of Association Ukraine will return to
good relations and associations with you
ready I'm not naive I'm an expert in
international relations the relations
between Russia and Ukraine deteriorate
that have deteriorated so much now that
there is no hope that they just in one
turn they will improve so it's not a
glue stick in terms of Russian
interested that I'm just expressing my
doubts it's my dogs it's not my I have
no right to advise either you or the
Ukrainians how to behave because if I
understand you correctly your main
argument is that based on this picture
one hell threat to the other half a blue
that the Ukraine is a divided country is
not one unified state which can make
well it certainly started as a unified
state and the only condition
to keep it that way and enjoy God's gift
in such a territory such economy such
science such high technological industry
the only Republic of Soviet Union that
left with industrial production of
high-quality sharing with Russian
enterprises the cosmic production for
for space etc etc so it's 0 now that who
needs that in European Union especially
that European Union is very egoistic and
it's very colonialist you know that it
doesn't allow the members to export more
outside the EU then they do in EU who
needs what Ukraine prepon produces now I
mean what it rests from 0 but it in
Europe eNOS nothing so that means that
hundred and hundred thousands of jobless
people who would lose because their jobs
because it will be the industrialization
of Ukraine that means d modernization
because of that they will rush of course
to European Union to seek a better
fortune are you ready for that listen I
in the beginning I felt slightly
confused telling the Dutch what to think
about themselves but when i see the
dutch can tell the Ukrainians i feel
very much free because I tell I kind of
problem with the referendum I have a
real problem with the referendum which
has nothing to do basically with the
russian-ukrainian story and he is where
my problem goes I very much agree with
you that there is a major gap between
the publix and deletes and I do believe
that the referendum is a genuine
democratic instrument in order for it to
work they should have consequences for
people because what I'm afraid of this
referendum is three things do you
remember how the Dutch government and
Dutch public has been a happy with the
Greeks in 2011 wanted you have a
referendum on the reforms saying
basically you cannot
keep yer oh the hostage of the greek
domestic politics why do you believe
that you can keep the common foreign
policy under you the hostage entered
that domestic politics and for me this
is a major issue because it's about
Europe this is I very much understand
that you can have arguments for or
against but here is what I am afraid I
tablet for example that the British
referendum is totally legitimate you
have to position people going to decide
and on the base of this decision some
important things are going to change in
the life of the Brits what is going to
change in the life of the Dutchman if
they're going to vote no nothing and
this is my problem with the referendum
it's very much kind of a low cost just a
tactical instrument to paralyze the
European Union and with respect Ukraine
this is yeah and do you know where is
the problem with Ukraine because of
course everybody but by the way for me
your plane is one of those countries for
which you I don't know everything for
you know nothing so I'm not going
basically to make any statements about
this but he is my story you are sending
a very strong message to everybody
Europe is closed we don't want to be
nice to people anymore from this point
to view the signal of the referendum
it's not very different from the Danish
people saying you should take basically
the values of the refugees not because
we want them but they should know that
they are not welcome but basically
killing the hope of people even if it's
a wrong hope it's not a crime it is a
scene because you're saying there if
you're going to get them the role and
basically leave their country what is
the message that we're telling the
Ukrainians well nobody is going to leave
Ukraine side we are helping Ukraine
since 2004 we have good neighbourhood
policy in Europe we try and take care
and help you fight corruption there are
programs with technical systems
financial assistance twinning projects
we do a lot we spent money in Ukraine
helping NGOs fighting corruption helping
NGOs bringing more rights to the gay
community doing all sorts of things the
Dutch have programs many programs in
Ukraine that cost us a lot of money and
I support that and I think we should
keep on doing that
and we don't need a treaty already it
was said that in the past 24 months many
laws have been passed in Ukraine without
this treaty so already Ukraine is
reforming and I was happy to meet many
Ukrainians who says that even if the
Dutch say no to this treaty even if the
Dutch say no we will keep reforming this
country because it is in our own
interest and that gives me hope because
it isn't in vicenza just for interest
free when she wish of the people of
Ukraine investiture to reform the
country and also to reform the political
system that mr. klimkin comes from and
represents just sentences because it
first of all I do believe you are going
to be right if the Dutch people were not
going to have an opportunity to have a
referendum if the you should basically
get Ukrainian but you have this option
Ukraine then what I do believe it's a
legitimate question should ukraine be a
member of the european union is not
something obvious but I do believe that
you have and you are going to have all
of the member states this option if this
question is going to come we are not
discussing this do you know what is the
message that basically we're sending the
world the message is if you want to
change your life it's not enough to
change your government better change
your country and then when people start
and basically said that the only way to
change is to go to Canada or you you or
us we should know that this is the
message that we're sending down and from
this point of view of course to be
honest I'm not fascinated by the
performance of the Ukrainian government
I can imagine a better government and
it's not about how well or bet they're
doing it's about the message do you work
in the beginning of a political process
to tell people listen we are in the
business of keeping you out this is for
me the Sun or even the message that you
are advocating is extremely dangerous if
you say that holding a referendum which
is the purest form of democratic
expression is holding
is holding the European Union hostage
then you are putting the institutional
interests of the European Union above
popular will and popular sovereignty
know you put that were killed Roger a
blog it was all Europe record we meet
when we've had no it that we've i'm not
against our [ __ ] beer that's not at
hand listen i guess i was years ago i
read a science fiction short story
romanian one by the way having
Bulgarians and Romanians on the stage i
know is not helping the ukrainian
clothes absolutely don't definitely know
but goodies but the story was the
following basically they come is the
political system in which when they
elect a president they were putting a
bump in his body and everybody his dis
on his phone the possibility after the
president takes a decision to vote yes
or no and gives three times the Noah
modern yes he explodes the only problem
it's a very democratic but I'm not going
to go this regime a democracy and by the
way I don't know anybody even the
Socialist Party spokeperson running from
the elections like this so from this
point of view I do believe that the
referendum is a very important
instrument but this is the nuclear
weapon of a democracy